[Music]
rich is taken by wrongdoing do no good
but what is right and good saves from
death
as iron sharpens iron so a friend
sharpens a friend
the tongue has the power of life and
death
[Music]
knowledge is of more value than gold
in much wisdom is much grief and he that
increasetheth knowledge increaseth
sorrow
[Music]
what has been will be again what has
been done will be done again there is
nothing new Under the Sun
words kill words give life they're
either poison or fruit you decide
[Music]
lazy hands make a man poor but diligent
hands bring wealth
for as he thinketh in his heart so he is
[Music]
a gentle answer turns away wrath but a
harsh word stirs up anger
do not let kindness and Truth leave you
bind them around your neck write them on
the tablet of your heart
[Music]
fools despise wisdom and instruction
keep thy heart with all diligence for
out of it are the issues of life
one man pretends to be rich yet has
nothing another pretends to be poor yet
has great wealth
[Music]
a fool is wise in his own eyes
the discretion of a man makes him slow
to anger it is his glory to overlook an
offense
[Music]
the glory of God to conceal a thing but
the honor of Kings is to search out A
matter
your own soul is nourished when you are
kind it is destroyed when you are cruel
[Music]
the righteous man walks in his Integrity
his children are blessed after him
one who is slow to anger is better than
the mighty one who rules his Spirit than
he who takes a city
[Music]
a wise man will listen and take in more
instruction
[Music]
start with God the first step in
learning is bowing down to God Only
Fools thumb their noses at such wisdom
and learning
[Music]
being cheerful keeps you healthy
a good name is rather to be chosen than
riches
[Music]
anxiety in a man's heart weighs him down
but a good word makes him glad
the sleep of a laboring man is sweet
the desire accomplished is sweet to the
soul
all the rivers run into the sea yet the
sea is not full
a wise son makes a glad father but a
foolish son is the grief of his mother
to gain riches is wise to pay for riches
with happiness is foolish
if you desire wisdom like money and
buried treasure then you'll find it
listen to your father who begot you and
do not despise your mother when she is
old
whoever stubbornly refuses to accept
criticism will suddenly be broken Beyond
repair
[Music]
riches are a stronghold in the
imagination of a rich man
[Music]
kindness and faithfulness keep a king
safe through kindness his throne is made
secure
better the anger of a friend than the
kiss of an enemy
without Vision a people perish
if you are honest you will live life
safely
but if you are dishonest you will get
hurt
better is the man of humble standing who
works for himself then one who plays the
great man but lacks bread
in the day of prosperity be joyful but
in the day of adversity consider this
God has made the one as well as the
other
do not rebuke mockers or they will hate
you rebuke the wise and they will love
you
a merry heart doeth good like medicine
a friend loveth at all times and a
brother is born for adversity
train up a child in the way he should go
and when he is old he will not depart
from it
[Music]
a merry heart maketh a cheerful
countenance
a slacker does not plow during planting
season
at Harvest time he looks and there is
nothing
wrath is cruel and anger is overwhelming
but who is able to stand before jealousy
[Music]
Pride goes Before Destruction a haughty
spirit before a fall
devise not evil against thy neighbor
seeing he dwell as securely by thee
[Music]
strive not with a man without cause if
he has done the no harm
turn not to the right hand nor to the
left remove thy foot from evil
go to the end thou sluggard consider her
ways and be wise
[Music]
it is better that you should not bow
then that you should bow and not pay
[Music]
first you learn humility then you
experience Glory
those who are right with God are
remembered With Honor but the name of
the sinful will waste away
[Music]
Under the Sun the race is not to the
Swift nor the battle to the strong nor
bread to the wise nor wealth to the
intelligent nor success to the skillful
but time and chance govern all for man
does not know his time
as the water reflects the face so the
heart reflects the person
[Music]
the sated soul will trample a honeycomb
but to the hungry Soul all bitter is
sweet
[Music]
do not boast about tomorrow for you know
not what a day may bring
[Music]
sir not a fool according to his folly
lest thou also be like unto him
wise men store up learning but the
foolish will be destroyed with their
mouths
the rich is the one that rules over
those of little means and the borrower
is servant to the lender
hatred stirs up Strife but love conquers
all transgressions
the wise in heart will receive teaching
but a fast talking fool will become
nothing
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments